[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
staples center got a new name and it's
going to happen around christmas time
i don't know how ha it happened that
quickly like mid-season staples center
gets a new name crypto.com
darren revell is on this topic as only
he can be senior executive producer of
the
action network
mid-season name change to
the naming rights to an arena how does
that happen
i guess dan uh staples is not selling
enough paper i mean
i mean they did a lifetime deal after
they did a big deal in 99 when it opened
they did this lifetime deal
um and you know what i think part of it
and this hasn't come out yet
they didn't they probably wanted out a
little bit and and crypto obviously
these exchanges are going nuts
and they have a lot of money and they're
trying to compete
and that's what happens um
it's interesting to me because it's
being reported as a 700 million dollar
deal it's like 35 million dollars a year
this is the first time i've ever heard
that a company has paid more money for
something that was already named right
because there's this value of like are
you still gonna call it the staples
center you've been calling it the
staples center for 21 years
i guess crypto.com didn't think that uh
there was going to be people that were
going to be calling at the staples
center to think there's real value
well maybe you call it the crypt
right but then you're not calling it
crypto.com
but i i don't understand the value of
this and that's why i want to have you
on you could help me understand this
because i know when i did sportscenter i
purposely did not mention
a stadium that had naming rights i just
said let's go to baltimore let's go to
chicago wherever it might be so
how do you get your money's worth out of
this and where is that money going to is
it just going to the lakers pockets and
that's it or is it
improved it's actually it's actually
owned by uh phil anschutz of anschutz
entertainment so it's aeg that owns the
staples center he is a part owner of the
lakers um
but you know what i think it's always up
to the individual company to make the
value work right like so are they going
to have like atms where you put in your
dollars and then you get a receipt that
you've turned it into bitcoin uh are
they going to convert points into what
the uh ethereum and bitcoin price is how
do they do it it's not good enough i
remember when when metlife stadium got
its name and i was just doing an
interview live on cnbc with the metlife
chief marketing officer said how are you
going to make this work and he said
something like uh you know just give us
a chance and i'm like
you don't have a plan
you don't go to like your ceo and say
the reason we're spending 20 million is
this is how we do it i guess at that
point he did not know then you're
definitely wasting money but i think
it's i think it's hard of course
everyone who invests in bitcoin is
applauding this and everyone who just
loves crypto is applauding this as
just to go to show you that this is
another way that we're big
i thought shaq should have gotten
involved and call it you know the shack
and and you know people would have had
fun with that he's got enough money i
get shake shack with shaq and you know
there you go
that that could work although shaq is
now uh his big chicken franchise is
probably going against shake shack okay
all right but that's why you bring me on
dan i know all the deals like if there's
a conflict i know all the deals okay
will we have a day in our lifetime where
yankee stadium is brought to you by
dodger stadium is brought to you by
that's a tough one
i mean uh
we we've gotten to geha fields at mile
high i mean you know
you know or or at arrowhead i mean it's
so it you know i think it would be
something at yankee stadium um
but i think the yankees would have to
fall on hard times for that to happen
yeah but money trumps everything
it does i mean if staples is worth 700
million what would yankee stadium or
dodger stadium be worth
900
billion
uh
all right so crypto.com the crypt
what could go wrong here
uh it could be like uh sponge tech which
was sponsored was inside every uh a
major league baseball and nba arena and
then all of a sudden it was like a scam
but i'm not saying crypto's a scam i
would say that uh maybe the business of
crypto isn't as frothy as it is right
now
and uh you know that that's probably
what could go wrong all right if i say
lone depot park
whose stadium is that
is that the uh lone depot park
i actually don't know who is it marlins
did not know that go ahead keep going
globe life field
next texas yes the yours american family
the the cincinnati reds brewers
oh
wow this is this is the um
if daryl is this if darren revell does
it exactly
exactly
first energy stadium
uh that is uh the
uh
uh
cleveland browns cleveland browns
lumen field
don't and no idea never even heard of it
seahawks
okay state farm stadium
uh that is the arizona cardinals yes
uh
t-i-a-a bank field
jacksonville jaguars yeah all right okay
i did i did okay but listen if i'm not a
hundred percent there yeah you know you
you i think the folks at lumen are
withdrawing their money right now tied
pods field
that's fake thank you
uh is this the anniversary of the
michael jordan shoe
this is so this is the day in 1984 where
jordan walked on the court with the air
jordans he is pre he previously wore air
ships which was uh the shoe that was
banned by the nba but not really nike
used that it was a black shoe with with
uh you know the red swoosh that um that
was that nike then said was banned by
the nba and that caused all the
marketing but yes against dr j on this
day in 84 uh he did wear the shoe and by
the way there is no evidence in any
article that anyone noticed it um scored
16 points in a loss but i collect
tickets and i think you guys have it i
have a ticket from that game yeah i
think we're showing it now if you're
watching on peacock
which is interesting because as people
are collecting tickets there's 23 graded
tickets of michael jordan's debut on
october 29th 84. there's only three
of when he showed up in the air jordans
for the first time so i kind of like i
kind of like it tickets tickets
collecting tickets have certainly picked
up in the last six months to a year what
would those uh original air jordans go
for
well the
earliest known air jordans just went
where he wore them in a game i think it
was against maybe san antonio his fourth
game
uh that just sold for like 1.1 million
bucks so the first ever air jordans i
think that's probably three or four or
five million bucks
what other tickets are valuable now
people love the debuts you know mickey
mantle debut sold for more than a
hundred thousand the wayne gretzky debut
sold for a hundred thousand i think you
know the scarcity on things are of these
are so
uh there's the numbers are so tight
right because like what did you do with
a ticket like before you'd put it on the
bulletin board you'd put it on a
scrapbook but like how did you keep
these things over time um
so we got this week we got this man's
leg tomorrow i have that ticket
um and then uh i think on
saturday we have i didn't give this to
your boys so hopefully you can see this
one
dan what is this
1982 cow
uh what is it oh it's it's a cal
stanford oh the band is on the field the
band is on the field and there's only
there's only four of these and i have
one of them i mean this is by the way
some of the good parts about tickets
that you don't get on sports cards
mcdonald's back the bears some of the
old and obviously the more defunct you
know if you'll get a knicks ticket that
has crazy eddie on it uh you know or the
defuncts you know some of these uh old
ads are kind of classic what's the white
whale that you're looking for
uh
i don't i really don't want to say it
but
uh no but um
so so i did manage to get the randy
johnson pulverizes the bird game very
rare very rare because it was a spring
training game there are only 3 000
people there i did manage to get that um
i'm looking for i mean i'm looking for
so many i did get recently i got the
fluty hail mary pass uh
very very difficult um but there's i
mean that's what's it's a search right
like with cards you go on ebay you type
it in you go oh it's there you know um
i'm trying to think of like what is the
one oh i did get the leelia uh uh tirade
from 83 that you know the cubs when he
when he when he's when he when he says
to the fans like half the world is
working the rest of your bums are on the
field like can you imagine today that
type of oh i i did get the dennis green
rant they are who we thought they were
and we gave him right away
uh and i do ha and i do i'm the only one
it's the only one that graded i do have
the uh mike gundy i'm a man i'm uh i'm
40. come at me i'm a man i'm 40. um
so the uh okay i am looking i got it i
got it i got it i am looking as part of
my rant collection i am looking for the
jim mora playoffs
i'm looking for i'm looking for that um
you you need help
uh my wife you need help you need help
um
uh
i think that's all i got for you
all right it's great to talk to you so
i love seeing you thank you buddy
daryn revell senior executive producer
of the action network